hey this is sort of uh sort of exciting
the David Pacman show is now within
Striking Distance of 1.5
million YouTube subscribers thank you
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
Pacman well hold on a second because
things are turning up this is actually a
really great thing for us there are very
few Progressive YouTube channels like
ours that are at the 1.5 million
subscriber level in fact I it's under
four
um we are extraordinarily close to this
Milestone and what we've started doing
is putting together a sort of calendar
of interesting things that will happen
the sooner we achieve this goal now if
we do nothing nothing at all just like
let subscribers climb naturally
we are slated to hit 1.5 million on
November 4th so we would make it before
election day which was originally my
goal but on a recent stream I floated
the question well
what might we be able to do to get
people interested in getting us there
more quickly and people have started to
contact me saying David here's what I'm
willing to do if you get to the goal by
x-state or by why date so we're I think
this is actually going to be really
really fun so if you have an idea of
something you would like to contribute
if we move the date up just email info
davidpackman.com so let me give you some
examples if we move the date up from
November 4th to October 21st and by move
it up it just means people subscribe
that's all it means just hit subscribe
and then it'll happen sooner if we do it
by October 21st this is unbelievable our
viewer Kurt has agreed to get a
panoramic back tattoo of Mount Rushmore
with five faces on it this is the tattoo
Biden Obama
Clinton
FDR and my face now I don't really know
how I feel about someone getting my face
tattooed on them it's a little weird to
be perfectly Frank but it sounds
interesting and Kurt is willing to get
that tattoo
if we move the date up to October 21st
okay if we move it all the way up to
October 5th which by the way we're 5 000
subscribers away it's completely
plausible that we do that we could do
that in two days if we if we really
buckled down if we make it to 1.5
million by October 5 and from Utah
suggested that I buy or rent a unicycle
and film myself riding it down the
street that's fine I will do that I will
buy I will find a unicycle one way or
another if we make it to 1.5 million by
October 5 and I will ride it down the
street and then one of our viewers uh s
Perez during our recent stream said
David if you make it to 1.5 million by
Yom Kippur uh one of the Jewish High
holidays which is October 4th I should
do the Yom Kippur fast now as a
non-religious Jew I have never done the
fast it's just I believe it's a sunset
to Sunset fast
I'm willing to do it and I will live
blog the fasting and how uh how it is
okay so that's if we make it by October
4th now the way I'm doing it is because
we don't want to just like have to pick
one of these things if we make it to 1.5
million by any of these dates
all of the things promised from that
date on should happen right so if we do
it on October 4th I will do the Yom
Kippur fast and I will ride the unicycle
and hopefully Kurt will get the
panoramic back tattoo okay so my request
to you is two very simple things one
subscribe to the YouTube channel that's
it it's free it costs you nothing just
subscribe to the YouTube channel and
number two if you're willing to do
something with our calendar here oh and
uh we're seeing the numbers shift in
real time if you're willing to add
something to the calendar email info
davidpackman.com let me know what it is
and we will get it on the wackiness
calendar all right very very good